karina drained a bucket of water let w
of t denote the amount of water w
measured in milliliters that remained in
the bucket after t seconds
which equation best represents the
following statement over the first 25
seconds the amount of water remaining
the amount of water remaining the amount
of water remaining
decreased
by an average of four milliliters each
second
each second so let me let me let me let
me rewrite this let me paraphrase this
and then maybe we'll be able to think
about the math a little bit they're
saying that the average
average
rate
of change
change
of the amount of remaining water so i
could say the the average rate of change
of w with respect to time
over
first
25 seconds 25 seconds
is equal to
is equal to
a decrease the water decreased
by 4 milliliters each second so it's
going to if we're decreasing if our if
our rate of change if w is going down
our rate of change is going to be
negative every second that goes by w is
going to go down by some amount so it's
going to be negative 4
milliliters i'll just write that as ml
negative 4 milliliters per second
negative 4
milliliters per second
now can we can we write this in a more
mathy way the average rate of change of
w over the first 25 seconds
well the rate of change of w is going to
be our change in w over our change in
time or so change in w over the first 25
seconds divided by the change of time of
the first 25 seconds which is just 25
seconds so this is going to be
so
our change in w
is going to be
our
it's going to be our
our finishing
amount remaining in the bucket so w of
25 that's how much we have at the end of
this interval that we care about how
much water is remaining
minus how much water we started off with
minus how much water we started off with
divided by how much time goes by and we
could say hey you know we finished it
second at the 25th second we started at
the zeroth second or 25 minus zero is
just
is just going to be 25. so this right
over here this expression i just wrote
this is the average rate of change of w
over the first 25 seconds notice the way
i wrote it i had when i write it like
this it might be a little bit clearer
this is our ending w minus our initial w
and this is our ending time minus our
initial time now this last part just
simplifies to 25
and they tell us that this is going to
be negative 4 milliliters per second
this is going to be equal to
negative 4. and the units up here in the
numerator this would be in milliliters
and down here would be in seconds so it
makes sense that this would be end up
being in milliliters per second but
anyway which of these choices have that
and i have one more choice down here
well this one over here looks exactly
like
what i just
what i just wrote
now an attempting one might be this one
up here and the only difference between
this this one and this one is that we
have a positive 4 over here but keep in
mind what this would imply
if w if if w of 25 minus w of 0 in order
for this to be positive because we're
dividing by positive 25 in order for
this to be positive then this would have
to be positive
then this would have to be positive
in order for this to be positive that
would mean that we have more water
remaining after 25 seconds than we do
after zero seconds because in order for
this to be positive this one has to be
larger which means that somehow the
bucket is filling up with water not
draining but we know that the water is
decreasing by an average of four
milliliters each second so if we're
decreasing this value over here needs to
be equal to negative you have to have a
lower value after 25 seconds than you do
initially so that minus that needs to be
a negative value and if you have a
negative value up here and you divide by
a positive value you should get you
should get a negative value and it also
makes conceptual sense the water is
decreasing the rate of change of water
with respect to time should be negative
because the amount of water is
decreasing